[Music]
around the time the musical hamilton was
a few months into its broadway run i was
on a street corner in new york talking
to two friends and the tony nominations
had just been announced
and i said something like oh that's good
for lin-manuel miranda that's amazing
that his first time at bad like his
first big thing gets nominated for all
these awards and one of my friends
corrected me and said actually no he had
a play before this that was also
nominated for many awards and
and i said this sentence word for word i
said oh so he's no stranger to the tony
scene
and as i said this i kind of
absent-mindedly drifted into traffic off
the curb
and came within
millimeters of getting hit by a speeding
bus i think one of my hairs even caught
it like it hit a hair on me
chris and i always laugh about it
because my final words would have been
oh so he's no stranger to the tony scene
for so many reasons i'm glad those
weren't your last words
so many reasons
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and i'm here
as i always am with my brother
chris
chin
hi justin i'm glad you survived that
near bus accident it was such an
uncharacteristic thing for me to say i i
like to think there's so many worse
versions of your last words it could
have been yeah you could have been
uh you know
in such fear that you were like oh [ __ ]
i know i wouldn't want to go down a
coward you'd be remembered that way yeah
so the reason that we're talking about
uh this experience that i had when i
said that slightly embarrassing
potentially final words um
is that
one of the two people with me that day
was our guest today kobe smulders
she's one of my favorite people i think
that'll be clear
in the interview um
but yeah you met her did you meet her
during
when you shot the movie with her i had
met her years earlier at a wedding at
nick nick vanessa's wedding shout out
um to weddings
i was across from kobe and and her
husband
uh taryn taryn killam from saturday live
very funny taryn uh kobe and i got to
know each other very well years later
doing this movie uh called oh that's
right it's called literally right before
aaron that's the title i one of the
worst titles in cinema history i i agree
i agree i and i i'm yeah it also i think
it it came out in the time when the word
literally
became
so misused in our culture yeah i hate i
i just hate literally and i'm guilty of
it yeah i do it all the time i use the
word literally for emphasis
when that's not how you're supposed to
god
my head literally exploded i say i'm
ashamed to say i i say things like that
yeah i'm so hungry i could literally eat
a horse well you have eaten horse that's
true raw horse yeah literally synonymous
with really like an emphatic word yeah
adverb yes i i literally [ __ ] my pants
that's a funny david cross bit where
he's like i literally [ __ ] my pants oh
my god that was so crazy so as dumb as
that title was
i think kobe smulders is
the opposite in terms of cool and smart
impressive impressive yeah i had never
met her
so i was just meeting her for the first
time yeah she was better couldn't have
been more charming and friendly
it's weird down to earth cool yeah
seemed really cool so cool i mean it's
hard to i like now i feel like we're
repeating ourselves but it's hard to
talk about kobe without using
superlatives like that it's it's it's
impossible because she's such an anomaly
almost i mean she's just such a rare
bird so for those who don't know where
she was on the show the hit show how i
met your mother for nine i think nine
years it was on yeah they did it uh she
was on the netflix show friends from
college and now she is
um in the marvel universe is that marvel
yeah she's first she's in the marvel
verse marble verse she plays maria hill
yeah she plays um an agent i'm sure
everyone knows that at this point
she had her career i feel like she's
been working for so long but just now i
think becoming
really fast i don't know i don't really
have a good gauge of
levels of fame well she's in this
spider-man movie now that's out that's
uh
doing very well so i think i think she's
hippo yeah people know her kobe it's a
cool name toby smolders she does smolder
by the way before we get into this which
uh
at this point you're all probably eager
for us to do um we just want to do a
little plug of our own tour plugging
ourselves yeah we're touring
we're going on the road we're sort of
like aerosmith yes yeah like like
aerosmith in the 70s god he got weird
looking not arrow smith
loving an elevator uh anyway going on
tour so we're going on tour it sounds
cool to say that it's fun to say that um
but we are doing three shows three live
shows coming up in september so if you
live in these cities
philadelphia brooklyn or washington dc
we're going to be doing shows there uh
tickets go on sale friday at 10 a.m
we're running an exclusive pre-sale for
podcast listeners pre-sale
password justin long you can access
tickets now tickets and information
available at www.justinlonglive.com
make sure the url is included in posts
and um
there's even oh i didn't know this
limited vip meet and greet ooh people
get to meet you and greet me whoa yeah
all right i'm doing the greeting the
shows are september 17th philadelphia at
underground arts september 18th brooklyn
at murmur and september 19th in dc at
the miracle theater uh so that'll be
really if we're gonna have some some
good guests uh for those live shows then
christian will be uh on stage you might
get to meet and greet me too yeah
you don't get to meet you get to
you get to acknowledge
uh you get to nod at me from a distance
yeah that'll be a throw well you've
always wanted
so that's in september
coming right up yes up next yes you have
to wait
uh we are going to meet and greet uh the
just fantastic kobe smulders
[Music]
to know each other yeah well we did a
movie together called literally right
before aaron which um and it's called
that
because
i meet this guy in the movie right after
dating you you're eric i'm i'm aaron
yeah so throughout the movie i'm trying
to get over you and i go to your wedding
the takeaway from our film was
yeah what mom want to hear this was the
best background acting i've ever seen in
my life
and i have footage of it because i
demanded that ryan send me it lovely
ryan hanson who was also in the movie
with us
and the shot is on us and it's kind of
on us with like crowd behind us so it's
all wide
and there's just this one woman in a
neon pink dress you know a 60 year old
woman who is just
facially
expressing her disdain for the cake you
would just pushed over the wedding cakes
spoiler alert spoiler alert in the scene
i i ruin i i try to sabotage their
wedding i do said it successfully and so
i push over this big three level wedding
cake and so they wanted a reaction from
the crowd and of course kobe's reacting
the way you know like a way bride would
yeah i guess that happened very natural
ryan's a great actor he's you guys are
very and and and upstaging the both of
you um is this woman who is just
her face is contorting in such a way and
it's frozen it's not only like
constructive but it's frozen in
contortion in like
i don't know what
for like a full-on 40 seconds yeah it's
fantastic it must have been hard for her
to hold this um you're supposed to be
looking at these two characters in the
foreground and this woman is it's so
great it's really wonderful it's
wonderful it was so fun uh that was the
greatest takeaway of that film for me
personally this is a cheesy like tying
that but do you have exes
in your life that you're still close
with or or who maybe i kind of burn them
burn it down yeah burn it down let it go
i don't mean to i just was like you've
been inside of me i feel like we can't
we can't i don't know how to move on now
maybe that's just because like you know
i haven't had a i've met taram when i
was 22. like
we were young you know so it's not like
i have a huge laundry list repertoire
sexual encounters but it's like you've
been inside of me i think that we can we
can part we can be like civil
um
and it's all good okay so that's not so
it's not but we don't have to keep in
touch no we don't need we don't i don't
i have friends yeah you know true i have
friendships close friendships i don't do
you is this yeah yeah with one
with one or two but but yeah i can i can
do it um
i wonder if it's easier for guys i don't
know uh if somebody were inside of me i
think maybe it'd be harder for me to get
over it since you're doing the
penetrating it's easier to i don't know
i wonder
and you met taran in l.a yeah did were
you guys working together you just
he was working with a good uh still a
very good friend of ours they shot a
pilot together this is taran killem who
was on saturday for a long time and one
of the funniest people you'll ever meet
the nicest the greatest i'm gonna say
the greatest man on the planet i hope so
yes um for me he's not the greatest but
he's nearly the greatest he's like one
of the top ten like the top ten oh
absolutely okay top ten men top ten men
yes
i would actually say that taryn's one of
the top ten men that i've met in my life
he's my number one i've met a lot of men
and i've been around god honest to god i
would say taren truly is one of the top
ten he's a lovely lovely man and i
really lucked out because like i said we
met when we were 22 and that could have
gone any direction yeah you know how do
you that really could have been a doozy
sure share your story
with the world with the secret of just
staying in a relationship
two actors for us and this is not for
everybody but
we're very independent
like i have never been like why didn't
you call me where where where are you
i've never had that unless i'm dealing
with a kid situation right that's when
that kind of stuff gets somewhere like
you're supposed to be a pickup bro where
are you you know but not like it's not
like i you know you didn't even you know
you were at the party you didn't even
check in with me like i don't have that
i don't have that in me it goes a long
way and and he doesn't either i i don't
know if that's an insecurity thing or
within yourself or within your
relationship i don't know i think it
would probably maybe both yeah maybe a
little combo did you were you very taken
care of growing up
like by adults yeah right
no that's right which is probably why
i'm like i'm good yeah yeah i've been
i've been rocking it solo styles for for
a while you grew up in vancouver i did
uh and you have to i did not have four
sisters
i have i just knew about your brothers
sisters yeah i have so i have my parents
my mother and father had four kids two
girls uh sorry three girls and one boy
and then they got divorced which is a
whole other podcast yeah and um
we're doing that one next that's the
next one that's gonna be a good one um
and my father remarried my stepmother
who had four children she had two girls
and two boys so it was you know uh brady
bunch yeah so did they integrate the
family i mean obviously they're yeah
i've been trying to since i was seven
but did so
was that a struggle or was it like um i
mean i was so young um i was i think you
know the timeline the like i'm a year or
two off probably but i think
they met when i was around eight or nine
they got married when i was
15. so
you know and the you know the the
youngest which would be my step brother
adam he's six years older than me so it
was a pretty big gap yeah yeah
especially adult they were adults yeah
to me yeah are those the ones that were
like i know they're like lumberjack
types no they're not lumberjacks they're
they're like dude they're like real like
you if you were they're like criminals
that's right i get criminals and
lumberjacks confused i mean that's
that's what the canadian criminal is a
lumberjack oh yeah no i mean it's
they're they're wonderful steel trees
they're wonderful people but they're
they're full-on bros yeah they're
like they're tough guys we have we have
running jokes about
um you know me being so i moved in with
my father when i was in high school and
high school in canada starts in the
eighth grade everybody and it goes from
eighth to the twelfth grade and one you
know one one campus
and if there was a guy who was
interested in me or you know at that age
you're not like having you don't have a
boyfriend but you do by label but you
don't actually yeah yeah
we're seeing each other like he's my
boyfriend i have yet to talk to him yes
but you're dating a very strong
relationship no we have never been alone
no we've never been we've glanced at one
another yes um but he would like um so
if somebody was interested in you would
he would tie them up and he would put it
up to trees
and throw beer cans
or like follow them home and i would
hear about it days later like i don't
even i don't even know that guy but it
was this weird you know very meta very i
don't know what well
then these are the your adoptive
brothers these are these are the step
these are the steps
yeah so he was i think when this was
happening he he was still on
no he might have graduated i don't know
he's six years older than me so he would
have been just graduated i guess are you
enjoying high school are you like are
you thriving i did very well i was very
popular
you're laughing you're are you being
sarcastic i can't tell you no i i i did
good i did well i did well i did well
it's so funny because now like i have
conversations with my daughter and she
was like
you know were you popular she's like 10.
yeah but it's a weird thing to be
you know popular is bad like popular is
kind of like you're a bit of a
back in the day it's like clicky and
whatever it is totally you're like one
of the heathers yes yeah i i was not i
was not that but i was voted most
respected by my high school graduating
class oh yeah so people like most
respected most respected we are the most
respected
that's canada for you yeah
that feels like the prize then if all
those prettiest i was very surprised by
it i was like huh and i said to some of
my friends did you vote for did you vote
for me was this a joke
it felt like a bit of a joke um
so people now do you ever see them you
ever go back home and they're like oh it
makes sense
this is canada i'm still like best
friends with all of my high school
girlfriends that's great i mean it's
i've never been to a high school reunion
because of that reason because i see
there's no need for this all the time am
i like to swear on this bike
okay yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah i didn't know
your full name i didn't know this oh my
full name yeah jacob francisca maria
smallers
with a kind of cool exotic accent
much cooler than i am
uh where did that come from
uh jacoba is the name of my great
aunt my father's dutch and his favorite
aunt she was named jacob but one by kobe
the whole life i've never been called
jacoba by anyone in my life oh wow um
even when you're a baby when i was a
babe no
it was always that you know legally
copa but we're going to call her kobe as
was this woman in holland francisco
maria um it just sounds so
so that's exciting it's well it's
catholic
you know which my family i guess was at
one point but not when you were doing a
formative year okay no uh so you were
raised with no really no well my mother
is like an atheist and my father i guess
would be catholic but is not practicing
i do i'm having a memory of like a
cartoon bible in my mind i think there
was an attempt at religion probably
through my oh my nopa which is
grandparents and dutch
that was a very strong part of your
identity growing up yeah really yeah
they all immigrated to um vancouver like
as a family and
like
apartments and more landlords and stuff
models we can play oh i know how
whatever i don't know how to say this
without sounding like an [ __ ] but i
know that you are how cool you are and
how that world may not be the most
uh something that you're drawn to
naturally but how did that how did that
happen um
it was when i was god 12th and i was in
summer camp there was this girl who was
like my first
female crush was beautiful and she was a
model and she just kind of came up to me
and said
you should check this out and i was like
okay i can travel places i was 12. i
mean i was a child i was like whatever
you do i want to also do yeah yeah um
because she was like i you know i go to
i go to new york and i go to you know
paris and yeah
that all sounded great to me so i
started doing that i mean i was in i
first went to new york when i was 13
with a parent
and then would spend sort of every
summer and spring break in
new york back in the day you could you
know you could make money on it you
could make some good money and then
scroll it away and try to go to school
and that was sort of my plan it was like
a mean so and it also wasn't something
that you
were going to devote your life to it
wasn't like oh this is because i think a
lot of people probably get into it
thinking like well now this is what i do
i'm a mom i guess so i was like a means
to an end i mean i hate having my
picture taken so i don't know if it's
because of that i think i've always been
that way because i remember just you
know for annoying family photos and
stuff i always felt very uncomfortable
so i me too but i don't know how i
survived for that long doing it and even
to this day now but um like you chose i
know not a great profession
but i think that's sometimes too because
school photo day was one of my least
favorite days i felt so uncomfortable in
there yes it felt forced and vain all
these and now i i regress slightly
whenever i'm on one of those
red carpet
oh man yeah you have to do so much then
especially promoting something like
avengers right right well i think it's
harder when you're doing a smaller film
yeah because then it's actually on you
personally that's true to sell it more
like with all the avengers stuff i'm
like i'm like one of you like a cog in
the like exactly i am such a small part
of this thing that gets me laid by my
husband
gets me super laid by my husband good
for you yeah yeah i'm totally having sex
with my husband no i'm excited
i'm glad we're talking to mike for this
one
uh because taryn is also like a bit a
glorious nerd i mean he's like he's yeah
he's so into this stuff this is his
world i mean i i think that's why he
does you know he's an actor and a writer
and he loves story and he's a big star
wars fan huge yeah and and a marvel fan
comic book fan
so when you got this part was he like
please please
or was it just like an easy decision
you're gonna do uh when i auditioned for
the avengers i didn't know what i was
auditioning for because they weren't
releasing any information they just said
i think they just had a female agent
they didn't even say
so taran was convinced that it was uh
for the wasp which is um evangeline
lilly
um the role now i'm trying to think of
when i actually learned who it was and
then he told me who they don't even give
you the size right they're very no well
joss whedon directed the first avengers
and he wrote scenes like full-on
five-page scenes which is very nice
for this screen test with um sam jackson
it was like me
and like five other versions of of me in
a room and we would just go one by one
you know
with the cape on so you wouldn't reveal
anything any costume underneath which
was weird because it wasn't much of a
costume back then but yeah we would have
to go on what do you mean you need to
wear a cape well you have to wear well
you don't really do it so much anymore
like a barber when you're getting
yourself yeah well like no yeah but
bigger than that like full body because
they don't want to because there's you
know cameras everywhere oh my god i mean
i don't have to do it so much anymore
but i did for the first one yeah because
it was like a suit i don't want to
reveal anything they don't want to
reveal what the costumes look like so
are you around the other person i mean i
know oftentimes you are when you're
auditioning you're around the other
people there's a waiting room oh we're
like all in here makeup together really
yeah yeah and i went i left going well
that i didn't do great i did okay once
you got it were they like just so you
know this is gonna be like a
six seven eight year commitment you know
i had to sign that before him
so i did know that oh okay i did like
understand
the commitment but for those you're like
no how many do you want yeah do you want
to go 12 15 rounds
40 50 years i know i'm i'm 50. yes yeah
yes i try to live that long i know i
know just to do this
is that still fun to you like to travel
around i remember uh you mean the press
tour of it all yeah traveling
yeah i like doing the like fast and
furious things yes i mean the biggest
press tour i didn't i think i went to
london with
the avengers
but i did this movie called jack reacher
with tom with mr tom cruise we went to
beijing and and um shanghai so cool
germany and london but i'm guessing
people there in those countries don't
really know who tom cruise is so
you probably have to like boost him up
everybody you guys this is action yeah
yeah what is that what is the best the
best way to travel is with tom cruise
i've heard that i've heard that but it
was from tom cruise so i figured every
every other like trip just seems like a
turd yeah that's a real delight i love
tom cruise i love she's an amazing
person people forget what a great actor
oh yeah such a great they don't forget
about it mcguire like i mean there's
he's so good in a few good men yeah he's
so good that like now those scenes he
makes scenes iconic and people i i you
know other things get overshadowed the
acting but um specifically we talked
about his running well there's a couple
stories oh tell me because i remember we
were running in sand or something we
were doing like a montage
kobe and i were like doing a monster
it was like the good times and it was so
hard to run in the sand and you told me
this story then well i think maybe the
one first of all i'll i'll preface with
you know my experience of running with
tom cruise was that right before i got
hired for this movies i just uh i've
broken my leg and was on crutches for
seven weeks and i also had a six month
old child you know my body was not in
none of its pink top tom cruise
appreciated that top gun
so i got this job and like immediately
started training and
he is
legitimately
fast yeah and i know this because there
were machines that we were both on so
there was a treadmill it would sort of
set a pace i'm running next to him and i
i will say he is i think his highest is
about 30. 30 miles an hour on that
[ __ ] track
it was insane you know for five seconds
or whatever it is but anyway when we're
shooting we're shooting in new orleans
it's
a thousand degrees outside we're
starting to interrupt yeah what are you
doing when you're next to them are you
talking to one another we're purely
running okay staring straight ahead
we're staring straight ahead and i think
we're running away from like a drone
okay so it's like we just sprint like
there's oh they're actually shooting
this it's like green screens oh yeah no
no we're in a park in new orleans
outside running from a drone
i was a very smart person to say you
know what i think my character um is
like faster than his character
because you know she's younger she's
more trained you know
and that was the only way i survived
that day because he had to i got to set
the pace oh he had and he had to run he
had to run behind me at my pace it's
been so hard for the first time i know
the first time that we did it he just
like left me
in the dust
he's so fast and they have compilations
of him
weights on his ankles
like weighted pants handicap in some way
just to make myself feel better but it
was so intense and we did i remember at
the beginning of that day the director
came ed zwick and he was like okay so
you see that red cone and it was a
football field i mean it was it was so
far away
full sprint to that and we must have
done it about 40 times
oh my god yeah it was like all my
training was just for this new orleans
new orleans in
humidity and he was totally fine and i
was like
oh my gosh she's crying and you're i i
didn't in the movie no
justin did not none of the running was
really in the movie oh my god how can
you have a tom cruise movie with no
rhyme there was a little bit of running
but i mean not they cut the whole drone
sequence i think you know i think about
that a lot well with our movie that uh i
shouldn't keep referencing because no
one saw it but um
i remember doing a bunch of pratfalls
that never made it and one one hurt me
well i chipped something in my elbow to
the point where i'm i still feel it
every time i once in a while and i think
it's a constant reminder of
i don't have to do it that much that is
one thing one of the many things that
tom taught me during that movie is how
to do everything safely and like you
know in those moments when you're
shooting and they're like just can you
just jump off of this thing we just need
this one shot you just no and to
actually
own that and to see i should protect
yourself you should have told me that
story the day that i got no he got hurt
i got heat stroke you know oh yeah
that's right like tom cruise this is
similar to tom cruise and you did two
movies with tom you did both jeff which
were just the second just though just
the second one yeah yeah and it's
different yeah did you ever talk to him
do you ever hear
yeah we email and
oh yeah
yeah and we get um you know one of my
favorite parts about the holidays is the
tom cruise cake have you heard about the
tom cruise yes i have what is this cake
like talk to me so
it's um white chocolate
coconut cake
i'm not a sweets person yeah but the
cake
is like it transcends that well it's
sort of you do you know like um what is
it called that um like that almond uh
marzipan it's a similar like marzipan
consistency consistency is the cake so
it's very moist
it might still be in my freezer i
[ __ ] chip away at this thing
so we always sense that and then he
sends like a giant gingerbread house for
my children it's so sweet for what it
just just because it's christmas
god i love him and i send him our family
christmas card he's a he's the hardest
working man i've ever met yeah and also
the most the kindest generous generous
to every crew member i mean he's just um
he's just a delight
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far
follow harsh reality the story of miriam
rivera on apple podcast amazon music or
you can listen early and add free by
joining wondering plus in apple podcasts
or the wondery app
[Music]
at what point do you
think well i i could i could maybe be an
actress because you didn't you did you
act in high
school you did you did the plays yeah i
was very into sports i played soccer for
12 years and then i um i played
volleyball and then i got into
basketball
i'm just like why are you laughing well
i'm laughing because i have a funny
story which i can tell
which is you know uh growing up my my
sisters and my older sister she was two
years older than me and she's
she was very good at basketball like her
whole life like she was the star player
on the on the on the senior team how
tall is she she's not she's not super
tall but she was point guard she was
like
um she's five nine five ten but she went
on to play college ball and then she
went on to play um in holland
uh she got her sisters dipped through
her father
and she played professionally played
professionally wow and she played on
like the dutch national team for a while
she's legit right i'm trying to make
make a name for myself
on the basketball courts of lord bing
and uh we were at a tournament and so
you know somebody shoots i go up i grab
the rebound everybody clears out
and for some reason
synapses got confused
and i went up and i shot on my nap
and i missed okay and i get my own
rebound and i go up and i shoot again
second time
and i miss and i get my rebound and the
crowd is going wild and i'm like
nobody's on me
this is it this is my moment now
when people do that they call it a coke
i know you know you smolder you pull the
smolders
and then i went up third time my own
teammate steals the ball away from me
and i have this vivid memory of looking
out into the crowd and the entire senior
team is watching and my sister is
sitting there with tears
flowing down her face because she's
laughing so hard in this moment i was
like yeah i'm going to go into acting
i'm really fully committing
now i'm getting back in the theater
company
so at what point after you leave school
you're still modeling
i left school and then i moved to new
york and i was like living in the the
meat packing district which is not at
all what it is now it was gross gross i
remember so gross and it was like just
in the literal way of somebody was
hosing blood off of the [ __ ]
cobblestone streets yeah that kind of
gross i'm surprised i didn't end up dead
a lot do you ever look back
for your periods you're like i've been
to just so many weird places and
traveled to so many countries yeah that
i'm surprised that i didn't at the very
least become a drug addict
while you're modeling while you're
living there yeah i'm living there i'm
living in a two-bedroom apartment with
eight other women on bunk beds it's so
so romantic weird why
well it's a it's it's
a horrible industry so first of all
let's just be clear it's a [ __ ]
horrible industry i know but tell them
don't tell the listeners to stop it we
know um it's a total racket i lived in
this apartment and i was paying which
was a lot at the time you know i was
paying like 2 000 a month to be in a
bunk bed in this apartment what because
they were charging all these girls
basically how it sort of works is
it's like a tab system right
come to new york we'll have you meet a
bunch of people you stay in this
apartment
and you're you're getting charged for
everything so they're so they're getting
charged for flights and you're getting
charged for like overly charged for your
apartment and you're getting charged for
every
xerox copy they make of every photo so
when i showed up at you know when i
graduated high school and i moved to new
york the next day i had like you know a
sixty thousand dollar tab that i could
never really crawl out of is
isn't there some sort of union or a ad
no i wish it was is there
no no idea that's why i'm so glad i
never became one
you were so close i could have so many
opportunities really go really hitting
it but i decided like i need to you know
go go home i went home i went back to
vancouver after that
and i actually was enrolled to go to
university at the university of victoria
to study marine biology that's right you
wanted to be a marine biologist i did it
i still kind of do yeah how close did
you come i mean i mean i was i was
registered i was all my classes were set
and then it was the summer before
and um i was still i think i was still
trying to make some money modeling
locally in vancouver or whatever and
then i started taking uh acting classes
and then you know those community acting
classes like you're bonded for life
because you're talking about you know
whatever happened to you when you were
the kid of course getting [ __ ] real
with everyone yeah yeah so it's really
more like therapy i was like whoa this
is like this is what i this is what i
want to be doing these are my people
yeah these are my these are my people
and
i might be able to turn this into a
living like i've done theater all
through high school and it never
occurred to me it never occurred to me
that i could make a living that's weird
maybe it's just because my parents are
not in they're not artistic in any way
and they're very like father's a dentist
my mother was like yeah she was a mom
for a long time but went back to school
and um
worked like with computers creating
databases and stuff and so it was
nothing i didn't think that i could make
a living out of it growing up and being
like you got to get a real job you know
it's one of those things yeah practical
and i'm a very practical person yeah so
yeah and so i just delayed it a year and
then and then never wins so then you
started going out on things in vancouver
yeah in vancouver and my first job my
very first job
was on a television show called special
unit 2.
what is the second unit for well it's a
special unit that only deals with
mystical creatures i i know this you
know why why
my best friend in the world john togo
uh-huh was on that show and so i knew
and then when he got that job that was
like a huge so i watched that show yeah
i got hired on
their like during our episode they got
cancelled oh okay and it was especially
rough because
they were back after the holidays or
something
and they're like all right guys we got
the back nine or whatever the order was
and then they changed their minds
everybody had just gone through the hall
it like a but isn't that horrible yeah i
bet you're
just they were not happy yeah and this
is my first set and i'm like this is
yeah this is how it's done and
everybody's miserable everybody is and
rightfully yeah i mean horrible that was
your first job i didn't know that was my
first job uh and so then but so now do
you think like oh they're just gonna
keep coming or did they keep coming well
i got on a good i got on a good run
because shortly after that i um you know
growing up and being in vancouver
especially during this time where pilot
season was a real thing you know there
was a bit of a flow to the year where
guy would anyway work in restaurants all
year and save up and then drive down
for like january to june here to los
angeles to audition for pilots
and hope that you could get on a pilot
yeah and then hope that you could get
the visa that you got from that show
right
so um so that's where you met taran too
on one of those trips down here well i
first i first auditioned i put on myself
on tape and i got this job i tested down
here and it was for the show this abc
show called veritas
no you don't know it nobody knows oh
really we might have had a conversation
about it but it was like god that sounds
a father and son team
and they were like he was the dad was
like an archaeological indiana
and
we shot that in toronto and we shot 13
episodes yes and after that i was like i
[ __ ] made it yeah that's it and then
and then um
well what happened a couple things
happened the first thing that happened
was
i came down to la to test for lost
i did not get it
and i was like whatever it's a show like
no one's gonna watch it watch that show
on to the next
and my manager at the time in vancouver
embezzled a [ __ ] ton of money from me
so i had
uh no money i had just like sunk all of
my tv series money into an apartment
because in in vancouver
and um so now i had this mortgage thank
god though you did that well yes yeah
yes
yeah it was probably it's good in the
long run but but then i you know i went
back to waiting tables and i just didn't
work for a year and a half like just
nothing that must be a strange feeling
going from like oh yeah yeah
the next one's gonna come if this isn't
you know it was a weird it was a
learning i'm really grateful for it yeah
quite honestly i mean i think everybody
should wait tables yeah just i think
that that should just be a human
prerequisite first life
because once you've
lived in servitude to other people and
you deal with all different types of
people
you really you know i can always tell
who hasn't and it's as simple as
not acknowledging
the waiters when they bring you
something right to me is like i can't
it's one thing if you're like in the
middle of like a some serious
conversation totally even then i i when
it happens um
around me i get so uncomfortable and i
feel the need to thank on their behalf
thank the waiters right right the idea
of somebody bringing you something and
not acknowledging them it's like yeah i
don't get it but but you but it happens
all the time um
you don't get lost you're back to
waiting tables i was waiting tables and
working for my mother as a gofer my
mother's british
what that definition means is that she
worked for a very small budget version
of geek squad right
so she worked for this like company and
you you you bring them your broken
computers and they fix them but i had to
go to people's houses and like pick up
their
freaking what are those called the
really heavy towers what's that called
um towers oh
like the the drive the the drive the
hard drive the hard drive yeah right i
have to like take the hard drive and the
monitors
i have a laptop um but they were really
heavy but they were heavy i put them in
the back of my mom's honda civic because
i couldn't afford to pay my car
insurance so i wasn't driving oh my god
my reality was i would bus about an hour
to my mom's borrow her car
drive all around the freaking city
picking up computer equipment dropping
it off and she pay me eight dollars an
hour what yes
and i did it because i you know i had to
keep my days free to audition and then i
would be working at night so so i would
do that all day
and then i would work in restaurants at
night god so you needed the flexible
hours yeah yeah exactly i couldn't just
get a day job right i had to yeah
so then i um
does that ever get creepy you go to some
strangers
i mean
i think there was only one house that i
started feeling a red flag and i
actually listened to it
was fine yeah i think i think i played
and this is you know
this is i had a cell phone but it wasn't
what it is now right so i think i i had
it sort of
on and i went to the door and i was like
i'm just gonna call you know the company
to make sure you know i'll just have
them on the phone while i gather it just
make sure i have the right
well you can use my phone yeah i got a
phone in here
where are you going outside um
again i could have been in a ditch
somewhere i don't know how i'm not yeah
i'm just one of the lucky ones i guess
yeah so are you depressed around this
time is this like [ __ ] what am i doing
with my life or is it like oh it's
something something's going to come i
think it was you know i was only this is
when i'm
you know 20 20 yeah i'm still super
young i liked drinking so working in a
restaurant was great for me yeah did
that for about a year and a half and
then i came down to uh los angeles and
then i auditioned for how i met your
mother you're 20 22.
22. wow and did you know that show do
you have any idea that show was gonna be
what it became no i had never done a
comedy before oh wow this is it was my
first comedy and i actually was going to
test for
i don't remember what it was called but
it was like a brother and sister wedding
planner comedy single cam
and mark paul got glosser
who i was legitimately in love with for
a portion of my life zach morris i i
almost referenced that with the cell
phone yeah um and yeah i
was going to test for that show and then
um the same casting director was like
can you come and read for this one
and then i read and i met with carter
and craig who are creators who are the
nicest human beings i mean they were
kind enough to to move um
i think i was like testing with mark
paul
like you know
a week you know from from meeting them
or whatever and they were able to make
the test happen before that so if it
didn't happen i could still
test for this other thing right which is
very nice yeah sure um so they must have
really wanted you too they must really i
guess i guess so i don't know um but
you're so now you're doing a comedy and
you're playing
you're gonna offer it to jennifer love
hewitt she turned it down she turned it
down jennifer love hewitt oof which is
funny yeah that must make you
i mean i'm grateful i love her yeah
jennifer love her
um
uh well wow
yeah i know what a mistake um
but uh but no regrets and we we're gonna
have jennifer on later today so i'm
gonna ask her about that jennifer's
standing by she's coming up next right
yeah she said she's right in there
i'm sure she has no hard feelings about
it do not feel awkward at all about
passing her oh my god so is that life
changing right away is that how how
different is your life you know i do
you're interested um
i'm not an optimist or a pessimist you
know but i'm somewhere in the middle
where i just go
whatever happens and for me
i achieved my goal of getting my visa i
was like i'm here that was it i'm here i
can stay here for six months yeah that
was huge for me
so that was exciting and so we shot the
pilot and i met taran a week before we
shot the pilot oh my gosh which is so
trippy wait where'd you meet him you
missed it we met well we met i went to
the taping of his of his show with my
friend he does not remember meeting me
at this show
but then
like a week or two later uh it was a
friend's birthday party um
and she was uh it was a 30th birthday
party so he thought i was very old
because he was like this chick is like
very mature well because you're friends
with this person yeah so i'm friends
with this person wearing a 30 year old
birthday we were at the that roller rink
up north somewhere here so uh so we met
there and we hung out and then pretty
much we went out like the next night and
we've been a couple of percent oh my god
wait what show was he doing uh he was
doing no he was doing a pilot
um with bill lawrence called nobody's
watching okay but yeah so we we met
there and it was this really weird thing
of like whose pilot is gonna go oh my
god
which is funny because we're in that
right now a little bit but i know that's
right so taryn is now on single
parenting turns on single parents yes on
abc wednesday night at nine o'clock so
right away is there is there
how does it change how does your life
change now that the show is a success
right away for for me it's about it's
still about stability it's still about
like okay we've got a pilot score i just
made this money from this pilot right
and then it was okay we're picking you
up 13 episodes and i'm like great oh my
god
you know but it's you're practical yeah
i'm very practical so i'm not like
even even for the nine years i mean also
the the blessing of this show really
there's many blessings from from that
show but one of the ones that i'm
thinking of right now is that we were we
did it for nine seasons but we were
never like
a huge hit
in the sense that our personal lives
were affected by it
but in terms of anonymity it must
no no really never recognize never like
never really approached we never got
wrapped up in any weird like the cast of
how i met your mother can't stand each
other whatever it's gonna be yeah um
while in it i knew
not to take it for granted i knew how
special it was now five years out i'm
like holy [ __ ] that i didn't realize how
that was the best i was right life could
be a dream sweetheart
hello hello against your booming we'll
meet again you
spoken about going through the bearing
the big c the big c yeah i went through
the big c while on that show which is
another reason i'm very grateful to it
god and because it was like i remember i
i got diagnosed and i had to go through
major surgery and i told pam fryman who
was our director
for almost every episode and i told
carter and craig our creators and i said
i don't know what's gonna happen i might
not come back so you have to like to the
show yeah yeah i said i don't know i
don't know and i remember them there was
like a moment like we gotta tell the
network and i and and pam was like nope
we're not telling anyone
we're gonna just take it
week to week
and um and we did and
it was okay are you even thinking about
the show or is the show so
distant in terms of your priorities i
was thinking of it because i'm like a
really hard worker and i don't ever want
to let anyone down so i think that i
think i was probably worried about that
about letting
the show down
and and them having to scramble to yeah
figure it out
i think about this often actually which
is like thank god i was on the show when
it happened because
you know say i'm i'm still doing this
canadian migration
of coming down here and like auditioning
or whatever still hustling
i would go back to canada to do all this
health stuff and i was able to
be here be working
be a member of sag
have insurance
so i'm very grateful and and also like
moving forward when i had my kid it was
like you know we'll make the schedule as
easy as possible and we'll shoot you out
so you can get home whatever you i mean
it was the best yeah it was the best so
if you are going to get cancer
be honest yeah and try to be on a sitcom
when you get it the best advice i can
give you if you're going through it
it's very empathetic get a sitcom
that's the best thing network prima
i'm a very private person i mean i
didn't tell the cast until
um i knew i was going to be okay
and in fact i got pregnant so
soon after that i was like i'm pregnant
also yeah i've been dealing with this
other stuff the lead
it's only this is the only way you can
bury that lady yeah it's something like
that
so
i'm fascinated that you went through
this at such an early age like it must
have been fear i mean i imagine like a
great deal of fear do you think about
the end do you think about what happens
after this do you think about
it
for me it happened so
fast which i think i had ovarian cancer
so ovarian cancer is like
nicknamed the silent killer because when
you actually find it
symptomatically it's very akin to like a
menstrual pain and it's very hard to go
like well this feels weird and then the
doctor usually says well you know when's
your period coming and then you say well
it's here and then they kind of ignore
it and it gets avoided for a very long
time
until um you know it's it's metastasized
until it's really in a bad place so
um i was lucky enough to to
have
uh what was called what is called a
borderline cancer which means it's not
quite benign but it's not quite
malignant but it's very angry and it
kind of it grows in it and it's um still
a scary thing but it's usually something
that's dealt with surgically i mean they
took a tumor out of me and it was the
size of a cantaloupe so it was like i
felt it and i was like this is
something i'm not pregnant
borderline cancer yeah borderline so
it's not what's so big
it's cancer-ish
how do you deal with it what i'm saying
is i never worried so much about my
mortality uh oh i was never like
deciding well guys
it's been great but i was you know i'm
25 when this happened
i'm been with sarah for two years you
know two-ish years
and they're like you're never going to
have kids you're most likely never going
to have children so you need to
rationally have to figure that out
that's okay so that's what you have to
do so that's that's what my main concern
and focus is but
i will say like i'm i can be a very
intense person
and i got the diagnosis i i went to
surgery a week later i i had this
massive surgery and then it was like i
went raw
i learned to meditate i did like [ __ ]
energy healing
i did
aerobatic medicine i did i went to this
cleanse retreat i don't know if i've
told you those stories i'm not gonna
tell you yeah you sure have they called
the
but he talked about his cleansing oh
it's mostly what we talked about he yeah
he has no problem talking about that
stuff he was he could not get over the
fact that i
uh
and i don't i'm not crazy about
having women
around there yeah yeah yeah he couldn't
he couldn't understand that right and to
which which forced us to then think
about how
pristine his butt must be he yeah yeah
maybe one of the best um i know too much
yeah okay
so you went through all the you were
like i'm going gangbuster i'm just gonna
have the healthiest system possible and
to that point
being grateful to how i met your mother
is like i'm on a tv show i can afford
totally to go to the best [ __ ] weird
crystal healer yes yes and wherever and
and i'm in california so that's very
available to me all this is we're on
every street corner right there people
on every corner
yeah who's your butt guy
does your butt stuff i have a great butt
person but um but um
i so yeah so i just i went crazy i just
did all this crazy crazy stuff and i
think i think what really i mean if
people are listening and you know
unfortunately well i'll answer that um
well once they get to the cancer part in
this episode they're gonna start tuning
in we'll we'll re-edit that so it's the
beginning it's all the time
with that good good yeah so speaking of
cancer life-threatening yes diseases um
but no i think what was the thing that
you think i think the thing that really
you know i mean i went to this cleanse
retreat for eight days i didn't eat
anything what yeah it was really i think
the only way i did it is because i was
like afraid for my life
it's this place and it's in palm springs
and it's called we care spa you can do
it people do it like before the oscars
or some [ __ ] like look great
and i was just there just by the pool
just i haven't eaten for six days yeah
people are like you're kind of like
fabulous oh you look great like i just
want to stay alive
trying to you know fit into my hair yeah
the rest of my life but i did look great
my best
greater
but i didn't eat for eight days eight
days how do you do that what are you
doing
you you have teas you have
granulated shakes
and
it was like and it's so funny i left the
place going i'm gonna come here every
year i'm gonna do this every year i have
not been back
because i had children you know and i
mean it's like you can't you know
but um but it was really like it's like
hitting a reset button in fact there was
three other women who were there with me
not maybe for the same amount of time
but they were all trying to get pregnant
and women go out there
to to cleanse their system and and they
get they all got pregnant why i just did
you as i as did i even though the doctor
said you will not be able to have
children naturally wow you won't be able
to do that you can you know we'll freeze
eggs and we'll do all this stuff but you
you won't be able to do it by yourself
so other than the pregnancy which
obviously is a huge difference in your
body did you notice other differences in
your body after you did this eight day
thing i did i mean other than just like
the severe things moving heart hunger
you know i i remember leaving they you
left this place and they gave you like a
salad and you're like and i was so and
it was the most delicious [ __ ] thing
i mean every
lettuce leaf every
carrot shred i was just like oh my god
avocado i was like this is
you're like bill murray and what about
bob have you seen the reason yes oh my
god it was so good is this corn hand
shucked
it was so delicious
and then i and then you know you slowly
you get back i mean i was like i'll
never drink coffee i never have alcohol
and you you know it's all about balance
yeah cut to a week later you're like i
know give me that sweets
um
so you get pregnant shortly after that
yeah
and then was that like oh i'm
all of the fears the cancer fears go
away is that like now oh no i was very i
was actually like very afraid to be a
mom i was not i mean i was just kind of
you were young i was young
i mean none of this has been in the plan
taryn is lovely and was like we didn't
think this was we're doing it now he's
so sweet and i'm just like this is no
i'm not i don't because i was kind of
coming i was coming to terms with the
fact that i might not ever have kids it
was kind of
that's kind of what i was spending my
time on was was dissolving some of these
these preset ideas i had for my life and
i was trying to
i was trying to you know put them to bed
that must be confusing to to and i'm
sure you did a version of that you
probably put psychologically you're
dealing with that and like so you now
you're coming to terms with not having
kids and now you're pregnant that must
be weird
yeah yeah it was a big adjustment it was
a big adjustment how instrumental was
your family were they around at this
point your mom your dad they were but i
really relied on taryn a lot poor guy
yeah
sorry
you know
you're both lucky to have one you guys
are yeah i agree a couple goals couple
goals but you kind of are you're the two
of the best um
what is your most commonly used emoji
these are just going to be quick fun
rapid fire rapid fire um what's her
go-to it's like the
face oh like oh no that one oh
yeah
charles nelson riley oh
if you could be a professional athlete
well you said you played soccer and
basketball and although do you
do you still harbor any like fantasies
of like oh what if i had that's
something i could have committed my life
to i do i do think i could have like i
would have loved to have been on like
the canadian women's soccer team uh-huh
that would have been cool uh if you
could have one snack food for the rest
of your life what what would it be um
nachos does that count or is that more
of a meal yeah not just how much you eat
that's true which is for me a lot uh so
you could have a whole you could sit and
have a whole meal of nachos yes doritos
into doritos i love a dorito i love a
sun chip um uh favorite movie of all
time um the princess bride
i sat next to wallace sean
on the plane a couple weeks ago and he
said um from allied in new york so i had
a long time
and he said at one point the um the
waitress brought over some
so you know refreshments and she's like
the orange juice one and he took an
orange juice and as he was taking it she
said don't worry i didn't poison that
and i thought it was odd and we kept
talking and um
and i said to him
do you think that was like a when she
said that about the poison do you think
that was a princess bride reference and
he goes i think so i think it was and i
said what did you get that obviously did
you get that a lot he goes
and he said this that's a great great
scene and he goes and i was expecting
him to be like yes and i love it and
it's great and he goes i get it every
day and i said oh
do you how does that make you feel or
something like that and he goes well i
don't particularly like the movie
it was it's about and i said why he goes
it's all about revenge it's a terrible
message to give to kids
and it never occurred to me that he's
right and he goes and when people yell
things at me in the street they say they
don't say inconceivable
it's like they remind me of my
speech impediment they go inconceivable
and i never occurred to me then yes
because it's a constant reminder of my
oh interesting so i kind of dropped it
but i so badly wanted to talk to him
about that movie um
uh other than la or vancouver new york
where where would you want to live have
you ever had fantasies about living
anywhere else well i would want to live
in vancouver canada where i'm from but i
do now have fantasies about living in
portland oregon oh yeah [ __ ] great
the greatest yeah i was just shooting
there a couple of weeks ago and it was
just what you shoot there i was shooting
a pilot there oh yeah yeah which is
basically shot the pilot in portland
they shot well we shot uh 11 days in
vancouver in four days of portland
i loved it so much the food and the
people and the weirdness and right now
it's funny because portlandia is just
slightly it's it it's kind of it it's
not that's why that show is so good it's
not like a gross exaggeration
if you could have dinner with three
people
living or dead
okay i would say um my cousin jeff who
passed away
um i would say
what did jeff do
jeff uh well he was a pilot and he he
died in a plane crash when he was 25.
yeah it was it was not good times i kind
of want to just keep it in the family
now okay i mean if jeff's coming jeff's
there well jeff it's jeff's i mean i
would love to like i would love to have
dinner like with some grandparents now
yeah as an and be like totally you know
what was it like raising my dad or my
you know if we're gonna keep it in the
family or we're gonna start in the
family yeah yeah and then and we're like
katherine hepburn
just for like a sprinkle of fun jeff is
like what is she doing here
um [ __ ] katherine hepburn be cool yeah
chill out
uh who's your favorite muppet animal oh
yeah yeah if you could have super x-ray
vision or hearing um super hearing which
would you god that's a good one that's
like a great superhero question not like
fly or invisible um the next one's flyer
in business
i think hearing just because i have such
bad hearing i think uh-huh if you had to
be one age for the rest of your life in
an age that you've i mean presuming that
you've been um what would it be
physically i think 32 yeah
you know sometimes i fantasize about
becoming a vampire uh-huh
i just i do too yeah you stay
because the idea of staying what i mean
i i would like to live forever i was
like but everyone would die be like i'll
find you
i'll make new friends totally i made
these friends confused i got all these
friends and family's fun i know
i have eternity to do that fine i know
do you think about it like you know some
like
like 28 to 32 i'm like i could have been
now i mean it's [ __ ] terrible yeah oh
yeah now
but but yeah that is so hard to make
friends now i i i feel great now so i
you know well well i i've talked to
other people who when they do go through
a a near-death experience like you did
even though it wasn't you said that's
not where you went mentally um
i wonder how much that informs the way
you think about death and your mortality
now do you do
is it something that you do think about
i do i mean i definitely do i still
definitely have like fear about it i
think you'll always have like this like
well it's coming back or well this is
probably what that is
um
i always like i have it in my back
pocket so if there's something going on
that's really stressful or causing me a
lot of anxiety i kind of i'm able to say
to myself hey we could be in that
[ __ ] hospital again yeah remember
that yeah it could be like that yeah or
you could be dead you know yeah i think
this is bad yeah i do have like this is
not as bad as it's ever been thank god
for that experience i mean like
i'm sure you have to
you have to find the silver lining in it
um and that is actually a really nice
silver lining it is is to have that if
you had to have a vanity plate like a
funny thing on a license plate oh oh
if you could if you had to boobs
boobs
just because it's so clear yeah that's
true that'd be funny also people would
beg like
force people to be like who's driving
back
who dares oh hi ma'am yeah oh you're
boobs yeah um it's also like i remember
when we had pagers and that was the fun
you know oh yeah of course writing boobs
uh okay really quick uh beetles or
stones uh beetles i can't thank you
enough this was fun and yeah
this is a new thing for us is like we
like to just let these peter out
awkwardly okay well it's happening
mission accomplished
so
that just smacked and
that was no good
so that just happened it happened i'm so
glad it happened i feel you know that
remember that
billy madison when he's like we are all
dumber for having heard that i
uh may god have mercy on you so i feel
the opposite of that after talking to
kobe i always do i always just love
talking to her i'm going to say
something that might be misinterpreted
oh i'm excited
uh you guys have a lot of chemistry but
when i say that i don't mean romantic
chemistry necessarily just as people
like you yeah it was like a really good
non-sexual yeah can you say that is that
i think so see i think i agree i think i
think i can say it say it and you can
agree with it because
you brought up her husband about 10 000
times
so it's pretty clear that you're
supportive of her marriage oh yeah i i
hate when people say goals but that now
i find myself saying it a lot so maybe i
just have to embrace that now i say that
we have actually we have had a lot of
guests who are in seemingly
really good marriages yeah and for for
act hollywood actors oh yeah it's very
inspirational she says things that and i
don't know again i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this but is the word
tomboy
oh bad now is that has that been uh
canceled cancelled oh that's a good
question i don't think we're
i don't think we're the authorities to
because she
strikes me as
a tumblr i wonder if tomboy is and i
could tell she grew up with a lot of
brothers she talks about growing up with
brothers older brothers
who are
sound like toms very tommy yeah a very
intimidating man yeah and i noticed
certain things she said that reminded me
of uh like what it's like growing up
with brother she she says at one point
she says you'd be a turd
you asked her if she was so close to any
of her exes she said
uh it's hard for me because you've been
inside of me i mean it's very like
certain things like that are uh very
like
i don't know i don't know if you can say
that when she was talking about a
relationship i could sense your jealousy
because i felt it too
when she was like you know it works
because we're both very independent and
neither of us feel the need to check in
there's a real sense of security i think
in both of them and when she was saying
that you uh you were like
oh god
you're like that sounds so great and i
don't know if i've ever fully had that
yeah well and that's right because i
think that's very rare you were right
you're right to read that much into that
sigh of mine i mean i've been in
relationships where it was like it's
been 15 minutes yeah you know you have
been yeah i've i've seen it yeah it's
you had it you've had that more than i
would say yeah
she was voted most respected in high
school that's which is an amazing
superlative yeah it is well it's
canadian it's canadian very canadian it
just solidifies my
that much further my love of canadians
at one point you pivoted from talking
about tom cruise doing stunts with her
and jack reacher to you doing pratt
falls and getting heatstroke in the
movie you did with her
and i
when you were saying that i i i
something dawned on me i i thought
it says so much about her as an actress
that she was able to convincingly play
opposite both you and tom cruise
it's like
that's one of the most insulting things
you've ever said to me but i get it i i
i mean come on yeah no no no oh i get it
i get it but but i can't totally get it
uh yeah and and both of those stories
are so perfectly symbolic of
why it's so impressive that she was able
to navigate both those types of people
i'll never forget that getting that
teeth struck how embarrassing it was i
got you have you ever had a heat stroke
no oh you get i i got i thought i was
going to pass out which is very
vulnerable as hannah b on the bachelor
would say vulnerable it's a very
vulnerable place to be
um and in front of all these crew
members and i remember i had been giving
i didn't say this but i've been like you
know being like
because i was the lead of the movie so i
was i wanted to like take care of
everyone and i was bringing them all
water because a lot of the crew guys
were getting light-headed and i got this
here's some water for you and in front
of everyone i got i was like oh wait i
gotta sit down you're like a damsel in
destruction yes
you're like blanche dubois
i was like i'm getting the vapors
uh and then i remembered everyone
looking at me who i had been like
heroically taken care of and i had to go
back to my trailer and this is a
low-budget movie where you have to shoot
you have to keep going i i puked i went
to my trailer and i threw up it was so
[ __ ] embarrassing and kobe could not
have been
a better person to have that experience
with she seems like someone who has
never
experienced anything bad you know like
things just work out i can't imagine
things not working out for her and then
she talks about getting cancer when
she's 25 and yeah the way in which she
dealt with it and talks about it
i found pretty inspiring and impressive
and impressive that how she really
tackled it she just went to work i think
about sometimes what it would be like
what i how i would deal with such a
you know serious condition and and i
wonder if i would just sort of curl up
in into a little ball i mean nothing
thankfully nothing horrible like that
has ever happened to me but i know um i
i wonder if i would like her resilience
and her her attack something to aspire
to i mean no one aspires to getting
cancer obviously but you know that's
also a litmus test for somebody's
character you know if when they're
facing a situation like no bitterness no
there's no bitterness just gratitude
that she got through it totally um you
talk about overcompensating with waiters
in terms of uh you know being friendly
with them
and you do tend to overthink yeah it
always bothers christian when we're
leaving a restaurant i i feel the need
to to thank
people when we're leaving this like
public loud declaration even at a like a
diner where no one gives a [ __ ] after
you pay the bill
justin's like thank you and like all the
patrons look up it's so embarrassing
but i would say i'm a i do a good amount
not to do not to pound myself in the
back but i think i do a good amount of
thanking you're very good at thank you
but you're right in that you should
skew you know towards overthinking than
underthinking i know but i do think it's
a good limits test on dates like you
like you talked about yeah knowing that
you are a consistent thinker and a
you know grateful person at that point
it becomes more like
i don't know like a thank you from
somebody who's not receiving something
doesn't really count that's true that's
not there because you you have been
brought in it's just it's just a uh
guilt
maybe uh reflex that you've like am i
shaming you too much in this
episode
no i deserve it
uh i it helps balance my guilt no no no
it's interesting you're right the final
impressive thing that i'm gonna say is
um
how she likes to quote unquote ruin the
magic
for a kid by bringing her to set and and
she introduces her to everybody all the
all the crew members and uh because she
wants her to
appreciate how much work goes into a
production like that and it's not
just about you know the star actor in
the project and it's a really smart
thing to do to your kids that something
tells me that that kid is going to grow
up to be oh my god uh just as cool and
grateful and grounded as her mother it
makes sense
those are people that i want sometimes i
meet you know i know certain couples and
i'm like i i hope you just keep having
babies like just to offset some of the
some of the duggars
yeah and finally i love her vanity plate
boobs oh yeah god damn it she's great
and finally we're gonna do a little
thing where we're gonna start doing this
after each episode at the end of each
episode where we read
a portion of an email that we got from
you guys out there
saying something about how you make the
most out of your life today's email this
is from anna it might be anna
m
and uh uh on i'm just gonna read part of
this letter i have uh honest as i have
severe depression i got help and i've
been doing wonderful since but the way i
look at life has been so different i've
become all about what's actually in
front of me instead of all the what-ifs
another thing i do is when i get upset
about dumb [ __ ] i ask myself if it will
matter in a few years if the answer is
no then i don't waste my time getting
upset i enjoy the little things more i
notice plants growing and animals
outside living together cohesively it
seems to help me appreciate more in life
when i look at the world around me and
seriously look at it not just pass it by
keep things light and not so serious
that's how i'd like to make the most out
of life um that's from anna m uh
and you know i was thinking about this
the other day i was having one of those
moments where i was walking i was just
taking a walk and i
found myself literally stopping and
smelling flowers
literally literally wow there you go
full circle wow um and it was so nice i
was like well but i caught myself kind
of stopped and smell the roses yeah
thanks for reaching out anna and if you
guys want to write in with how you make
the most out of your life it's
life is short at wondery.com we want to
thank everyone who has written in so far
uh some of them i think are maybe a
little too personal to read uh
and uh but we wanna we're reading them
all so thank you and it's been really
really moving life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
thank you again for listening to life is
short or thank you for the first time if
this is your first time listening to
life is short we hope you keep listening
we're available on apple podcast spotify
google podcasts and every major
listening app as well as wandery.com
life is short is hosted by me justin
long
it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco our senior producers
michelle lanz engineer is marcelino via
pondo executive produced by marshall
louis and hernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
uh
you've never seen like the boys on the
like the wolf boys from like
why do you keep saying wolf boys like
the ones with hair all over their face
like they're are they human
they call them like they're in like
national enquirer and stuff and like but
it's a real condition you've never seen
that
all right do you have your phone with
you no i don't really get wolf boys
this is scary no it's sad it's just sad
i don't see that either
well it's a little scary maybe i mean i
wouldn't scare you it'd be so all right
if one came to the door i'd be scared
introducing the next riddle they're
they're they're parents
they're the ladies
[Music]
a boy with hair all over his face
think about oh wow look look
the
blizzard of the month oh man we never
got no [ __ ]
i think they have one like 30 minutes
away um
by the way how spoiled i'm so i just
realized how spoiled i am
it's 30 minutes away
that we have to drive that far we get to
go to like
oh my god we have to eat that at all
i could not leave this conference right
now i know and now and and we get to be
like
sedated we live in a time where we can
eat a little candy and it makes us like
i
but i know i can have that tomorrow and
i'm seeing it
isn't that crazy yeah
it's a wolf boy you wouldn't be scared
of what boy came to doing
you